[Music]
both of the coast mountains of British
Columbia it's a beautiful part of the
world take both your poi and we're gonna
go through something that I think is
very high on the list of very important
fundamentals that will open up poi
spinning for you and that's learning to
reverse one poi while the other keeps
spinning which it ultimately just means
having control of different ation of
your right and your left poi so it can
be reversing employee in the longer and
it can also just be going bigger or
slower than the other poi or even
reversing and changing the planes
compared to the other play but we're
going to start simple so take both your
play and we're gonna build up from what
we already know which is the feeling of
reversing so if you spin your right boy
you can stall it and reverse it stall it
and reverse it and do it a few times and
really notice how do you do it what's
the feeling when you stall and reverse
stall in a hearse and see how
nonchalantly you can do it just you know
you know see if you can you know pay
attention to the other hand when you
reverse the right poi or look around tap
your feet when you reverse the right
play you want to be able to do it with
just a little bit of your of your
conscience left boy same thing get it
spinning stall it and reverse stall and
reverse so you can rub your right
fingers together and pay attention to
that when you reverse to get most of
your mind on your right hand as you
reverse the left
okay then you're gonna do this
just let the right play hang and see how
you can just sort of wobble your body to
get it rocking and then swinging now get
the left boys pinning and you're gonna
do that so right place hanging then you
get it wobbling then rocking and then
swinging this might not be this one I
make this look easy but you might find
it's not so easy that as soon as they
get swinging the channels get confused
and it all messes up and that's okay
just come back to it a few times today
maybe tomorrow it might take a couple
this then we're into the other POI so
get the right poi spinning and you're
learning it to the left poi rocking
until it's swinging front to back
so once you've got that with both poi
let's return to where we started so the
left poi spinning the right poi is
swinging and notice this at time when
they're kind of both going forwards
forwards from there you can get them
both spinning forwards then try to let
the right poi just go back to just hang
and if they both mess up don't worry
just get the left going again get the
right play back back to swing until you
can go from swinging into both forwards
Boehner do the other way where the right
is spinning and the left gets swinging
until they're both going forwards okay
so see how we're building this up then
you're gonna do this get the left poi
spinning the right pull you get swinging
this brings up the front up the front up
the front in the backwards and they're
going in opposite directions now this is
probably this for a lot of people this
will be the hardest part so you might
have to keep building up so try just the
right toy swing and swings up the front
to go backwards do a few times swings
and swings it swings up to go backwards
so maybe you have to rehearse it 10
times left pulley spinning forwards
right boy swing swing swing so go
backwards
opposites if it doesn't work just keep
trying do it the right way on its own a
few times then try it while the left boy
is spinning until you are in opposites
then you at the other side get the right
boy swing left boy swings swings swings
to go backwards and if I call spinning
swinging and swinging spinning it's a
blue a tongue-twister opposites awesome
and again do it until it's pretty it's
not a bit nonchalant so you're right for
spinning and the left click and going
back or the left point spinning forwards
and the right play can go in the
backwards when that's all working you
can start with both pull you're ready
both players spinning forwards and let's
say the left foot is gonna keep spinning
the right poised going to stall swinging
the backwards then you can stall it in
front and swing it back in the forwards
then the leg poi is going to stall in
the backwards then it can stall back in
the forwards so right stalls and
reverses then it stalls and reverses
again left stalls and reverses then it
stalls and reverses again if you're
feeling ambitious you can work towards
doing this you alternate right reverses
opposites left reverses both player
backwards right reverses you're in the
other opposites left reverses you're
back to where you started
right reverses left reverses right
bloopers
reverses now this is going to become
this opens up a whole lot of things a
lot of transitions in poi as you'll
learn all these different moves and
patterns how you move between them is
often with you reverse a poi and that
takes you from one pattern to another so
you're in your weaves and chases and you
reverse a poi and then you're in your
butterflies and your opposites and in
your reverse of poi and then you're in
your reels or maybe you have one fast
and one slow and or maybe you do all
kinds of funny patterns it the sky's the
limit
we're gonna come back to this over and
over because it's not only does this
open up moves patterns and tricks it
also makes everything else easier to
learn because if you can tell the
left-hand one thing well they tell the
right-hand another thing that makes the
learning process a lot smoother so
practice it it's worth it and we'll come
back to that and some lessons later on
you
[Music]